- Welcome back, everybody.
We've got Jay Ellis with us.
Give it up.
- Ayo.
- [Kelly] Ayo.
(applause)
So Jay's new movie is called
Somebody I Used To Know.
It's named after the Gotye song
Somebody That I Used To Know.
It got us thinking about
how many great movies
share names with songs.
So it is time to see how many we can name
with a game called I
Like The Way You Movie.
(Jay chuckles)
♪ (jingle plays) I like
the way you movie ♪
Oh, love it.
Lord, can you help us out here?
(ethereal chime)
- [God] Well, I certainly can, Kelly.
How you doing girl?
- I'm doing all right, Lord.
- [God] And there he is.
Wendell Ramone Ellis, Jr.
I'm looking at you, son.
How you doing?
- Yes, Lord.
I'm good, Lord.
- [God] I know your full name.
Don't you play games with me now.
But I'll tell you what,
I love you in that Top
Gun: Maverick. Mm-mmm.
That volleyball scene, that's
what I'm talking about.
That beach scene.
(applause)
You guys all oiled down and everything.
Okay, let's get to the game.
- Lord, is feeling frisky.
- [God] Now what I'm gonna do is,
I'm going to give you a hint to a title-
- Okay.
- [God] That is both a
popular movie and a song.
Now you're gonna hit your
button if you know it,
and you can steal if the
other person is wrong.
- Ooh.
- [God] Now there's a cool prize at stake.
If Jay wins, it's gonna go to the men.
Make some noise, men.
(men cheering)
Lone men in the audience there.
- [Kelly] Whatever.
- [God] And if Kelly wins,
it's gonna go to the ladies.
(ladies cheering)
- [Jay] Okay, okay.
- [Kelly] That's right. Yeah.
Outnumbered.
I'm ready.
- [God] First title. Brace yourself.
- Okay.
- [God] In the song, she's
walking down the street;
In the movie-
♪ Pretty woman, walking down the street ♪
- [God] It is Pretty Woman.
- Yeah.
Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god.
Okay.
- [God] Uh-oh.
- Oh, I'm feeling good, Jay.
- [God] Already with the smack talk.
Pretty woman, kind of
girl I'd like to meet.
- Here we go.
- [God] Here we go. Here's the next title.
In the song, the singer offers
help when you're not strong;
in the movie, Morgan Freeman-
♪ Lean on me ♪
- Oh, man.
- [God] Lean on me.
♪ When you're not strong ♪
- [God] Look at that.
♪ I'll be your friend ♪
- [God] You are right, son.
- Fine. I know. I don't
wanna be friends with you.
- [God] It is Lean On Me,
starring Morgan Freeman, whoever that is.
Okay, here's the next title.
In the song, the levee was dry;
In the movie the
apple-filled pastry was not.
♪ Bye bye, Miss American Pie. ♪
- [God] American Pie.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. I'm coming back.
- [God] Got ourselves the game here.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [God] I've seen some very
attractive strudels in my day.
Love one another, I say.
Here's the next question.
Kenny Loggins encouraged people
to take off their church shoes;
in the movie, Kevin Bacon-
- Oh! Oooh!
- [Jay] No!
- Um. Uh, uh...
♪ Footloose. Footloose. ♪
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- [God] Footloose. And
now Kelly is in the lead.
Kick off your Sunday shoes.
It is time for the final question.
(air horn blows)
- [God] There it is.
That's the air horn.
That just lets ya know
it's the final question
in case ya forgot.
This one is worth 10 points.
- Oh my gosh.
- [God] So get ready.
In the song, the clock
struck upon the hour
and daylight faded;
- [Jay] Wait, what?
♪ I wanna dance to somebody ♪
- No!
- [God] I wanna feel
the heat with somebody.
You are right.
Kelly has won.
- I won on a Whitney song.
(air horn blows)
- [God] That's it. Kelly's the winner.
Winning for all the ladies.
- I feel so good about that last one.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I didn't know, but I do love-
- God, she rigged this game.
- It ended with Whitney. That was awesome.
Okay-
- [God] Don't you talk back to me.
- Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
- Of course, everyone is a winner
on the Kelly Clarkson Show.
Emeril Lagasse Forever Pans
were created with the home chef in mind,
so they're dishwasher safe, oven safe
to 500 degrees, and stackable.
And you're all getting the
10-piece cookware set. What?
(Kelly imitating air horn)